Twitter is now going to be paying it's
uh it's pers personalities to generate a
certain amount of uh Impressions
basically Twitter will operate in a
similar way that YouTube does that if
you produce content that gets views and
those views deliver ads you get a cut of
these ads I was pleasantly surprised
rather abruptly to get a pop-up on
Twitter that said they were paying me
about six grand and I'm like I don't
even I don't even do anything like I
barely even use Twitter but I want to
pull up this tweet from Brian
krasenstein the uh I think Brian has
been on a terror lately with some
excellent tweets and this one is very
good uh for those that are familiar he
is a liberal personality but check out
this one this is good he tweets the most
entertaining outcome is the most likely
outcome I believe it was Elon who said
that wasn't it or is that a quote from
somebody else that's musk yeah you
answered that and he goes blocked by
Trump on Twitter in 2018 unblocked by
Trump on Twitter in 2019 banned from
Twitter in 2019 unbanned by Elon in 2022
made 25
000 from Twitter and 2023 at this rate
I'll be CFO of Twitter by 2024 and
Trump's VP by 25.
so uh here's what's funny about this
story
of course we'll get into the Twitter
stuff but uh Taylor Lorenz you know
where you love her wrote far right
Twitter influencers first on Elon musk's
monetization scheme I love it Andrew
Tate I am pretty sure that Brian
krasenstein the liberal Biden voter made
more money than edutate and the the
krasensteins because it's his brother as
well even pointed out that between them
they made way more money than some of
these other personalities and Taylor
Lorenz is calling it far right and
omitting them from the story I
far-righted before we came I came over
to here for the uh the show I went to
the gym and I was doing cardio oh geez
I'm sure that JoJo from jurors and
Brooklyn dad
are doing fine on Twitter as far as
monetization but yeah uh they don't get
it from Twitter though they get it from
the DNS yes exactly right uh did you say
Kellen earlier that you said that uh
that um Taylor Lorenz was offered to box
with Ashley Sinclair I think Ashley
Sinclair offered yeah it's never gonna
happen
we've had him on the show before but uh
Brian responded to Taylor's Taylor
lorenza's article for those for those
are not familiar with this context
Taylor Lorenz is a notoriously bad
journalist who has written a false and
misleading stories
so in response to saying far right
Twitter influencers make money he said
you might be reading the Washington Post
article by Taylor Lorenz and be thinking
but Brian krasenstein made twenty four
thousand dollars from Elon he's not far
right all I can say is I work out and I
said I warned you Brian Brian he posted
a video of him working out and I said
you're going to become conservative
that's how that's how it goes start
going to the gym
yeah and then uh Ed crescentstein uh his
brother also criticized this very
heavily saying it was factually
incorrect noting that there were
right-wing personalities posting this
but that they had actually made more
money than a lot of people this is the
media's game what happened is threads
comes out by Instagram it sucks it's
horrible Elon then launches as
prescribed in February that there would
be rev sharing like YouTube does and
other social media platforms do
Instagram and Facebook do and now
they're acting like it is a big scheme
to bribe people to stay on the platform
and they're acting like it's the far
right so let me get this straight does
YouTube bribe people is BR yeah all of
these liberal personalities and leftists
stop they refuse to pay for Twitter they
stop using Twitter and then when the
people who actually use the platform get
paid they go aha Elon Musk is bribing
people it's like dude the crescentsteins
used the platform stuck to the platform
they're liberals they made money
at any rate this is a very very big deal
in that there is now a viable platform
for monetization outside of YouTube
look I I tweet random nonsense I have
1.7 million thousand to it I don't know
why but thank you for following me on
Twitter now I kind of know why now I'm
like oh I should post Clips onto Twitter
I should I should post content there we
should simulcast the stream or do
something like that on Twitter because
now there's an opportunity to break the
censorship market and shatter the the
the the censorship
get all those hot takes you've been
saving up forever and just start
dropping them one by one so you can
start making money I mean the the thing
is you I don't know what it if they've
got like special rates for people that
produce content that's exclusive for
Twitter or what the deal is going to be
but you know a place like this produces
plenty of content to put up on on the
old Twitter machine you know I think
it's awesome over the last few weeks
you've seen with The Young Turks uh I
can't remember her Anna Anna and now
with the krasten's teens I don't want to
call it a red pilling because I don't
think it's quite that but they're kind
of seeing just how crazy the cult is
right because they got paid from Twitter
they're right wing now like come on man
so I hope the crashing scenes kind of I
think they know I think they realize how
kind of extreme the left can be at times
and I I think definitely Anna knows from
The Young Turks but it's been awesome to
witness you know from like a back seat
kind of perspective over the last few
weeks because she does not want to be a
birthing person yeah no no bonus holes
that's why everyone's upset
so yeah
[Music]
I heard it that way yeah that one ends
up in the chat very often that one ends
up in the chat very often when you're on
when you're online
I mean I don't blame her you know but
we're just seeing like the mob online
come after the crassensteins and The
Young Turks and it's over nothing I mean
seemingly nothing just having a
difference of opinion we had a uh on the
culture War this morning we had uh two
drag queens one was a more leftist drag
queen one was a not really left or right
just an uh older drag queen the uh Kitty
demure and maybe a girl were the two
drag queens and uh Kitty uh the drag
queen's name I suppose uh I believe it's
Kitty I could be wrong but I was saying
look you know kids should not be in
these things these are for adults these
are nightlife these are nightclub things
these are party things and uh the left
was saying uh more otherwise that was
basically the argument
but the interesting thing about it was
the uh the cult-like ideology that
persists in the left's view and there
was a moment in the show the reason I
bring this up is that I think the the
drag queen the leftist may have stumbled
into something inadvertently which could
cause problems for them I criticized the
book genderqueer
at the end of the show saying
conservatives have criticized this book
without reading it and they should read
it and uh many and you know post-liberal
thinkers and anti-woope people have
criticized the book without reading it
they should because they highlight this
book genderqueer as having graphic
images that shouldn't be shown to kids
that's correct but the book is about
this individual this author's deep abuse
and Trauma growing up from abusive
parents being forced to reuse menstrual
products for for days on end to the
point where they smelled horribly were
pulled out of class not being able to
read till 12 having to uh go about their
you know relief business outside
and uh maybe said thank you for that in
response I don't think that thank you
will fly with the cult on the left and
that I think whether I'm right or wrong
my point is just my perception of it
there is a clear fall in line say
whatever you're supposed to say no
matter what it is no matter how silly
silly it is
or else whereas whatever this faction is
it's conservative liberal libertarian
people disagreeing on a ton of issues
but like kind of just being chilled with
each other
yeah I get called bigot by other
Libertarians just because of my stance
on that particular issue just because
you're a Libertarian just because I'm a
Libertarian yeah but what is what is up
with that I mean let's talk about that
because um
you know Joe Jorgensen and it was I
think it was 2020 right tweeted that uh
that that cult worship line it is not it
is not enough to be to not be racist we
must be actively anti-racist which is
basically a cult Mantra it's like
effectively a a neo-marxist prayer to
see a Libertarian tweet we must do
something was kind of hilarious to me
like we all must do this things like I
thought we were all about individual
liberty and responsibility I'm curious
your thoughts on that element of the
libertarian party and those ideas yeah
I'm uh I'm all about the individual
um and not necessarily the party itself
I was a Libertarian well before I even
knew what the party was when I was kind
of looking for my identity you know back
when uh McCain and Sarah Palin were were
running and I just didn't like any of my
options so I mean I adopted ideology
just because it's it it makes sense to
me you know you don't hurt other people
you don't take people's stuff and you
just kind of mind your own business and
live your life but you know now you have
the government coming in and ultimately
trying to make decisions for you both on
the left and the right one tries to to
police Your Existence and the other one
does now the same thing and tries to
take your money along with it and you
know that they're they're redefining
Society now in a culture war that
doesn't even seem to make sense to me
um and they're drawing lines in the sand
that you know I've talked to people in
the L the G the B and the T communities
and they're all in agreement right and
then you have the qias uh and I don't
even know what the in the A stand for
but intersex right in uh queer
intersection asexual but there's more
than that there's two two s i uh you
know two Spirits right yeah and yes and
then like there's a bunch of other
letters that go into it but I mean I
feel like with with the T right I I feel
like a lot of that is like with the body
dysphoria uh and the and the in the
middle aspects where the Q is more just
how I feel today well so here's the
interesting thing I mean I mean the the
T does encompass what uh the drag queen
earlier was saying is Trans non-binary
in which people will be gender fluid
that's how they describe it boy are you
about to find out oh yeah but here's
what I see with the the progress pride
flag it is at one point it was a rainbow
flag to symbolize you know the LGBT
community then they added these Stripes
to it then they added a triangle to it
then added a circle to it they're
basically like
it's like The Horde in World of Warcraft
you guys know that what that reference
is yep it was these various bands of uh
fractured cultures that came together
and so the idea behind that flag is
aggrieved groups forming under one
Banner
they don't necessarily make sense it
does not make sense to have a gay pride
flag that includes black people well
because not all black people are gay I
mean the the insinuation that this is a
pride flag for gay LGBT Pride
and all black and brown people are
component of that doesn't seem to make a
lot it's it's not the same thing have
people started I feel like people
started calling it the progress flag do
you feel like that's I believe it's
called the progress pride flag okay
maybe this is all just a really good
plot from a flag maker who just wants to
sell you a new flag every couple of
years because they have to keep adding
things to it constantly it's just all
about oppression it's called the
progress pride flag and so it's got uh
it's now got black brown sky blue pink
white a yellow triangle and a purple
circle it's basically just putting
symbols of aggrieved groups into one
flag what's the purple circle uh I
believe that's it could be asexual okay
is there a white diamond maybe it could
be interesting nothing white nothing
white there's a white stripe
too yeah but we know what group is not
included and that's well no no so the
progress pride flag does have a white
triangle on it and that's because uh uh
the what is this okay so the progress
pride flag right here the largest
component of it is a white triangle and
that's because they all uh agree that uh
they think white people are the most
powerful and you know of course they
want to make sure they're represented
perfectly on their flag I'm kidding by
the way
it is true there's a giant white
triangle on the flag maybe that's for
the white women there's no there's no
explanation for the white triangle is
it's really caring I mean maybe that's
where the power of character is stored
let me look this up but what what are
the colors what do they mean okay so
let's see the progress pride flag and I
pulled this thing I pulled up on my
phone for whatever reason said what do
the rainbow stripes mean red is life
orange is healing yellow is sunlight
green is nature blue is harmony purple
is Spirit okay what do the triangles
mean the light blue light pink and white
section represent transgender yeah the
black and brown stripes represent
marginalized communities of color the
black stripe represents those who have
been lost to AIDS
holy wait what really
that is I feel like that's deeply racist
to say that the black stripe for black
people is the aid stripe is horrifyingly
racist I think the brown stripe is wow
people of color and the black stripe is
fur no no no look I'm I'm look I don't
know this is kansascity.com this is a
looks like a
um it's so annoying oh his websites are
terrible this is a Kansas City Star
and it says that the black stripe
represents AIDS and black people
I feel like depending on where you go
They're gonna have a different
definition for this flag it's part of
what Tim was saying how it's like uh War
of Warcraft or World of Warcraft how
it's all these random groups under one
Banner thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at
8pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time